All right Michael, you know the answer?
>> Yep.
>> Okay, what's the answer?
>> Do you want to know the value of the whole game?
>> No. I want to know the matrix.
>> [LAUGH] Okay. So right. So, if A goes
left, it doesn't matter what B does. And at that
point there's a chance node, and it's 50/50 for negative
20, which I feel like ought to be, negative eight.
>> That's right. How'd you get negative eight? because half
of 2 is sorry, half of 4 is 2 and half
of -20 is -10. So -8.
>> Right, so you just took the expectation of where you would end up.
>> Exactly.
>> Okay. What next? And that, it doesn't matter what b does. So
then negative eight is also in the upper right corner of the matrix.
>> Fair enough.
>> The next easy on to do is if both go right. A goes
right and b goes right then we get the three. It's just sitting there.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And the last thing requires me to do
some multiplication. So
>> Rrr.
>> -5 times 0.8 Is like -4.
>> Mm-hm.
>> 10 times 0.2 is like 2 so -2.
>> That is correct Michael.
>> Shoo.
>> So now we have the matrix. Now, what did
we just notice here? Remember what I said about matrices before?
>> It has all the information that you need.
>> Right, so in fact none of this matters.
Who cares how we got here?
>> wait, but, but, oh.
>> [LAUGH] I love erasing stuff!
>> So here's the thing, we cannot reconstruct that tree from this matrix.
>> We can't reconstruct, well, actually we
could reconstruct that tree from the matrix.
>> No, we can't.
>> Yeah, we, of course we could.
>> Yes, we can, because there's an infinite number of
trees we could do, and one of them is that one.
>> I see.
>> We just don't happen to know that its the right one.
>> I don't think that's really what people mean when
they say I could reconstruct this. Like I could reconstruct
the crime at this crime scene, it could be any of
a million things. Like no, we can't construct that specific tree.
>> But you know what it doesn't matter,
because the only thing that matters is the matrix.
>> Ahh.
>> And you will notice, Michael, that you did all that multiplication
and you multiplied 0.8 times 5 and after a couple of seconds of
thinking about which was probably edited out but I know how long
it took you do. You came up with the right answer. That's great.
But notice that the number you came up with doesn't say anything about
expected values and what the probablities are. It doesn't even matter that it's
nondeterministic, because once you have these
numbers, these expected values, that's what you're
going to end up with. So who cares what the original tree was? Who cares
if you can reconstruct it? Who cares what the rules of the games
are? All you know is I have a choice of two strategies. We
call them left and right here, but we could have called them one
and two, or Q and Z. It doesn't matter. For the purpose of solving
the game. So what is the solution for the game by the way?
>> Oh, A is trying to maximize right?
>> Yes.
>> So A would never, ever, ever, ever want to go left.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So A's going to go right and then B is trying to
minimize. So B is going to go left and we get the -2.
>> I believe that is correct. And it
makes sense the other way as well, right? That
B would not ever choose to go right because
then A would choose to go right as well.
>> Gotcha.
>> So you'll still end up here.